soldiers from two countries on the hunt
for one common enemy
troops from uganda have joined their
counterparts and democratic republic of
congo hoping that together they'll
defeat rebels from the allied democratic
forces or adf
their targets include the drc's renzori
mountains where the armed group
established itself more than 25 years
ago
our ugandan allies carried out an
airstrike across our border earlier this
week now together with our drc troops
we're on the move on a mission to push
out the rebels in the region
it's an unusual collaboration between
uganda and the drc but both governments
say the adf poses a threat they can't
afford to ignore
the armed group is accused of having
links to isil and killing hundreds of
people in village rates in northeastern
democratic republic of congo
and uganda blames it for suicide
bombings last month in its capital
kampala
we're very happy both governments are
working together we've suffered and
cried because of all the insecurity and
killings
we support it and encourage both armies
villages like these often bear the brunt
of the violence
entire communities have been displaced
and regional leaders fear the fighting
can spill over to other neighboring
countries
we are ready to defeat the terrorists
and we are ready to bring peace back to
eastern drc
ugandan troops say they're ready to stay
in the drc until the rebels are pushed
out but critics fear the presence of
foreign troops could lead to more unrest
and perhaps to the rise of other armed
groups
katya lopez al jazeera